happy Halloween Karen warden would film
courage the radio show and i'm here with
craig wilson of mental eclectic and san
diego in depos and craig hosts his own
events and we've been to san diego indie
fest think it was the sixth annual and
that was a great time you also have
another event coming up shorts and
spirits yes shorts and spirit showcase
it's a it's basically it's 45 minutes
for the short films we have a this time
because it's our one-year anniversary
actually we have a couple guest speakers
and some networking and you know it's a
great event it's kind of low-key but
it's it's a lot of fun oh and uh
actually film method is gonna be there
taping the show for us and doing some
Q&A with the filmmakers yeah they'll
method another great podcast what I'm
curious about because we've been in the
same boat is you're doing these events
and I understand you used to do one a
shorts and spirits in both LA and San
Diego once a month so that's two events
a month is that right yeah I mean how
how do you balance that because you're
also filmmaker you also have your hands
and a bunch of other stuff so how do you
handle doing those events because it's
great promotion for you it's segues into
other opportunities but it's also a lot
of work and it can be draining you know
I just don't sleep um it's a very
difficult process for sure you know and
um it takes a lot of determination and a
lot of sacrifice of I you know there was
for a while where I didn't do anything
but film like nothing I never went out I
never liked hung out with my friends I
kind of I am a huge freaking baseball
fan like the season just kind of flew by
and next thing I knew we were in the
World Series like what happened so you
know I used to like pay a lot of
attention but like all my time has been
spent in filmmaking and so it's a weird
delicate balance and on the creative
side like I you know I I was doing it
twice a month and one of the reasons we
started to just go quarterly and now
we're only right now it's just in la is
because I ideally I want a direct for a
living and I kind of the events are
definitely very helpful but I kind of
just want to walk away just a little bit
you know so i can put more effort into
writing and directing and actually
getting out there because i have my
reputation started to be it's not really
about reputation but people just started
to like see me as just a networker and
just an online guy and i was like that
when somebody said that to me is like oh
yeah i really just see it was this
online promoter and that's who they knew
me as and that's what I do I mean I do a
lot of that I mean I try to be as
supportive to the indie film community
it's possible but it's like that it kind
of snapped at me like no I want to be a
filmmaker you know I'm a filmmaker not
just this online promoter so I got back
to us yeah you know and it's interesting
too because i think that there's a time
when you have to just kind of lock
yourself in front of your computer and
let all that stuff germany and kind of
grow these seeds and these fans and
followers when do you know when it's
time to walk away from that because it
can be almost an addiction it's like you
come home and you're just in front of
that computer I know because I do it
with David when you know you know what
it's time to actually get out there and
start doing other stuff put content out
there instead of planting these seeds
and getting facebook friends and Twitter
followers what is it time to cut that
chain and from that computer that's a
really good questions I don't personally
figure it out yeah um I mean it does
take some something discipline you know
I've got so many ideas of projects I
want to do and I've got a couple things
burning but uh you know that's why I try
to find projects I actually have two
dates you know like hard due dates that
I know I have to fit
by then because that that drives me to
like walk away from facebook and twitter
for a little while and do it and
sometimes i just try not to even open
either of those period while i'm on the
computer because i always find myself
getting distracted you know or somebody
hits me up online and says hi and I'm
like oh what do they say it and then
next thing i know it's 40 minutes later
I'm like I mean if there are such great
tools as for us indie filmmakers whether
you're promoting your film you're
promoting someone else is probably
whatever you're doing but such a
distraction to it's a delicate balance
very elegant